[Music]
welcome back we're now going to turn our
attention to look at some future
challenges and opportunities and what we
sought to do with this discussion was to
broaden it beyond just space exploration
to look at some other challenges related
to air transportation energy and
environment and the order of the
sessions was chosen in a particular
manner to sort of set a contrast it's
already been identified that some of
those challenges are very different in
character from the challenges of Apollo
or indeed the challenges of the future
of space exploration and by putting
these things next to each other in some
contrast we hope that it will draw some
clearer distinctions between them it's
my great pleasure to introduce our
keynote speaker for this session the
Honorable John P Holdren dr. Holdren is
assistant to the president for science
and technology and director of the
Office of Science and Technology within
the executive office of the President
prior to joining the Obama
administration he was the Teresa and
John Heinz professor of environmental
policy and director of the program on
science technology and public policy at
the Kennedy School of Government he was
also a professor of environmental
science and policy at Harvard's
Department of Earth and Planetary
Sciences and a director of the Woods
Hole Research Center he also co-chaired
the independent bipartisan National
Commission on energy policy he holds a
degree in aeronautics and Astronautics
from our department and a degree in
theoretical plasma physics from Stanford
so very broad background he's the author
of some 350 publications on global
environmental change energy technology
and policy nuclear arms control and
non-proliferation and science and
technology policy
member of the National Academy of
Sciences the National Academy of
Engineering and the Academy of Arts and
Science and he's one of the first
recipients of the MacArthur Foundation
prize fellowship and thinking back on
some of the comments that Ted Sorensen
made this morning related to the Pugwash
Society also note that in 1995 he gave
the Nobel Peace Prize acceptance lecture
on behalf of the Pugwash conferences on
science and world affairs Pugwash is an
international arms control and
scientific cooperation organization in
which he has held many leadership
positions please join me in welcoming
dr. John Holdren
[Applause]
well thank you Ian and thank all of you
it's certainly a great pleasure for me
to be back at MIT with so many old
friends and particularly a pleasure to
be back here on the occasion of this
symposium on the next giant leaps
looking back on the achievements of the
Apollo program and all that followed and
looking ahead to the new achievements in
aerospace science and technology that
the great challenges before us are going
to demand my own trajectory from
undergraduate and master's degrees in
course 16 more than 40 years ago to my
current position advising President
Obama on the full range of Science and
Technology matters that are germane to
the policy issues of the day I think
illustrates in a small way both the
wide-ranging relevance of the
disciplines that come together in the
study of aerospace science and
engineering and it also illustrates I
believe the enduring value of an MIT
education and because there are a lot of
students I know in the audience I'm
going to dwell on that history for just
a moment how I came to make this
transition
my main focus is as an undergraduate
here were on fluid mechanics and rocket
propulsion in the Aero and Astro
Department and on electromagnetic theory
and space physics in the physics
department I had the privilege of
learning from some of the greats in all
of those domains and to my amazement I
had the privilege of talking with them
one-on-one in their offices
even as a freshman which is one of the
many things I loved about the Institute
we used to call it the glorious
Institute in those days I don't know if
people still do in the summers of my
undergraduate years I worked at Lockheed
on reentry aerodynamics on the orbital
mechanics of reconnaissance satellites
on a blade of rocket nozzles for the
poseidon submarine launched ballistic
missiles and then the collective senior
project in the class of 65 in course 16
turned out to be designing a manned Mars
mission I was the co-leader of that
effort with my classmate Jim Hester we
named that project project Ares
interestingly enough
I suspect the report is still on some
shelf in the department library as one
of the highlights of that effort doc
Draper who was the chair of the Aero and
Astro department at that time had the
whole class flown on an Air Force c-54
to Cape Kennedy for spring break and we
got to see the main assembly building
and the crawler and the whole works it
was just extremely exciting for a bunch
of MIT seniors in Aero and Astro to have
that experience which Draper was able to
arrange because he held the honorary
rank of colonel in the Air Force among
many other honors he had for my master's
thesis here I worked with Professor Jim
McCune on a problem in theoretical
plasma physics and that domain had come
to interest me both for its fascinating
science really at the intersection of
fluid dynamics and electromagnetic
theory but also for its simultaneous
relevance to astrophysics to defense
science and technology into the alluring
challenge of harnessing fusion energy in
the course of that work I was inspired
by the great MIT fusion scientist and
nuclear engineering professor David Rose
to think about how fusion might relate
to the larger and wider challenges of
energy supply and demand worldwide what
then ensued as Ian mentioned was a PhD
in plasma physics which I completed
jointly in the Aero and Astro Department
and the Institute for plasma research at
Stanford that was followed by a job as a
physicist at the Lawrence Livermore Lab
engaged in both energy and weapons
applications of plasma science and
technology my experiences there helped
turn me into an energy wonk but they
also helped turn me into an arms
controller preoccupied more with how to
reduce the dangers from nuclear weapons
than with how to further improve their
performance and earlier while still at
Stanford I had started to work on the
side with Professor Paul Ehrlich and
other biologists there on the
intersection of energy and resource
technology with problems of population
and environment and with the Caltech gia
chemist Harrison brown on issues of
science and technology for economic
development all of those threads then
came together in interdisciplinary
research and faculty positions at
Caltech Berkeley and finally again
Xion mentioned at Harvard in the Woods
Hole Research Center where I focused in
variable proportions on energy on
environment on nuclear arms control and
non-proliferation and on the theory and
practice of Science and Technology
Policy and I think it was that
collection of focuses more than any one
of them that then president-elect Obama
thought a sufficiently good fit with his
needs in a science and technology
adviser to offer me last December 15th
the immense privilege and opportunity of
serving him in that capacity for the
students the postdocs and the young
faculty members and researchers in this
audience and I think you're my most
important audience today with all
respect to the senior statesman of space
science and technology who are here the
lesson in this lucky life I've lived at
the intersection of science engineering
and public policy is that you have more
options than you may think you have many
of you will stay focused for all of your
careers in or near the scientific and
engineering specialties in which you've
been mainly trained I think it's
important that many of you do that for
we will continue to need specialists in
these domains in abundance but for those
of you who feel as I did the pull to
cross the boundaries of disciplines and
not only within the Natural Sciences and
engineering but across the larger divide
to the social sciences and the domain of
Public Policy I'm here to tell you that
the science and engineering training
that you have gotten and are getting at
MIT and even in lesser institutions with
which I'm familiar such as Stanford
Berkeley Caltech and Harvard is is a
is a strong foundation a strong
foundation from which to do that from
which to cross those boundaries now let
me now turn to my main topic for these
remarks which is a little broader than
the one advertised in the program I'm
going to talk about the intersection of
aerospace science and technology with
the great challenges that the United
States faces as a nation and the ones
that we all face as a globe I will talk
about the advertised topic of energy and
environment and aerospace technology as
well but I'm going to talk more broadly
as I expect many of you would want from
someone in my current position and
excuse me I thought I heard a comment
from the floor but my closing
introductory remark is that we do need
along with more specialists in
individual disciplines or small subsets
of them we do need more specialists and
wider interdisciplinary integration and
I hope some of you will take inspiration
from the many successful examples in my
generation and generations in between to
follow that path let me then come to the
main messages of my talk today
first of all science and technology and
Science and Technology education are
absolutely key to meeting the great
challenges we face as a nation and a
world in the 21st century aerospace
science and technology have been and
will remain a crucial contributor to and
driver of many of the relevant
capabilities and a key point here is
that President Obama not only
understands these realities he's putting
them into practice in his priorities his
appointments and his policies even so
achievement of everything we need from
aerospace science and technology is
being impeded both by long-standing
inadequacies in federal budgets
coordination and execution and on the
space side and the arrow sides alike we
have some big challenges here the
solutions are very much a work in
progress we don't by any means have all
the answers yet
overall budget stringency in and after
the current economic crisis is going to
remain a major challenge and I'll come
back to all of these points in a bit of
detail let me start with what the
challenges are that we face and that
preoccupy the president obviously
economic recovery and growth and in my
domain the issue there is the role of
Science and Technology as drivers of
recovery and growth Infotech biotech
nanotech Green Tech and other kinds of
tech that we haven't even thought of yet
have roles to play their second big
challenge and preoccupation is
healthcare we need to find ways to get
better outcomes for all Americans and do
it at lower cost that is also an area in
which science and technology have an
important role to play in energy we need
to reduce our dependence on unstable
parts of the world for oil supply we
need to reduce both conventional and
heat-trapping pollution from our energy
sources other resource and environmental
issues toxic substances sustainable
agriculture water supply adaptation to
climate change all big tough issues
where science and technology are going
to play a role national and homeland
security where scientific intelligence
cyber and power grid security nuclear
and bio defense are all important parts
of the challenge global challenges
deploying science and technology for
poverty eradication for development for
voluntary fertility limitation combating
preventable and pandemic disease
transforming the whole global energy
system we must do no less and land-use
practices to avoid catastrophic levels
of climate change we're already
experiencing dangerous climate change
the question is are we going to be smart
enough and quick enough to avoid
catastrophic climate change we need to
reconcile the competing human demands on
land and water for food fiber biofuels
and ecosystem services and we need of
course to maintain the ecological
integrity and productivity of the oceans
again these challenge challenges as well
as the strictly national ones are going
to be immensely demanding of Science and
Technology going forward reducing the
risks finally from nuclear and
biological weapons a tremendous
challenge still a tremendous set of
dangers although many people think they
went away
at the end of the Cold War they did not
there are some cross-cutting Science and
Technology foundations of success in
grappling with these challenges I
formulate them as follows one of course
and very much at the top of the list is
the capacities and the health of the
institutions that do our fundamental
research our universities our national
and private laboratories another again
very close to the top of the list is
science technology engineering and math
education preschool to grad school and
indeed lifelong we need that not only to
be sure we get the next generation of
scientists and engineers we're going to
need to address these challenges but we
needed to get the informed citizenry who
can be effective participants in a
democracy where science and technology
are more and more a part of almost every
major policy issue the availability
capacity and robustness of our
infrastructures information
communications transportation and energy
our capabilities in space which I put in
red to indicate I have not forgotten the
topic and that brings us together here
today international cooperation in
science and technology an immensely
important cross-cutting
foundation certainly going forward and
what I call the supporting institutional
processes and guidelines issues of
intellectual property transparency
scientific integrity visas export
controls all of those issues essential
to get right in for to get all of the
rest right now let me turn to the
relevance of aerospace science and
technology fundamental research and the
quest for knowledge of course the Hubble
the International Space Station's
experiments including the Alpha Magnetic
Spectrometer that's to fly on the last
scheduled shuttle mission before the end
of 2010 human and robotic exploration
STEM education space has played an
enormous ly important role in this
domain and we already heard a lot Y
about why this morning Sputnik in the
space race of the late 50s and 60s
inspired a generation of young people to
study science and engineering one of my
inspirations to study science and
engineering certainly and revitalizing
space science and space exploration
alongside new challenges for science and
technology for clean energy better
health and innovation for economic
development and growth can do this for
us again we can inspire a new generation
with these major issues to which science
and technology have so much to
contribute but it's not just about
science not just about exploration not
just about inspiration it's about a lot
of more nitty-gritty things
infrastructure military and civil
satellite communications military and
civil geo-positioning the efficiency
capacity and safety of the air transport
system Earth Observation and national
security tracking capabilities and
activities of potential adversaries arms
control and non-proliferation monitoring
and verification early warning battle
management the other side of Earth
Observation civil and multi-purpose uses
of space for observing the earth weather
forecasting storm tracking monitoring
the atmosphere oceans vegetation and
transitions and land use under climate
change and other influences immensely
important spin-offs into other domains
of the economy health care environment
and security and here I offer a quote
from President Obama's speech to the
National Academy of Sciences on April
27th where he talked about the spin-offs
from the Apollo program to those of you
who have not read that speech by
President Obama at the end of April at
the academy I invite you to do so it's
on the White House website it's on the
National Academy website really an
extraordinary speech talking about the
importance and relevance of Science and
Technology to the challenges we face
today and emphasizing among other things
the enormous importance of fundamental
research even when nobody knows where
it's going this brings me to President
Obama's initial initiatives in the
science and technology domain I'll start
with priorities reflected in his
rhetoric since I've just shown you a
quote from one of his speeches he has
put scientists and technology front and
center in his campaign in his
inauguration speech in his speech to the
joint session of Congress in his speech
of the National Academy of Sciences even
in his speech to the Islamic world in
Cairo where he rolled out a number of
initiatives for expanded science and
technology cooperation
with muslim-majority countries his
priorities have been reflected in his
appointment seven members of the
National Academy of Sciences are in top
positions in his administration I
suspect that has never happened before a
Nobel laureate in physics leading the
Department of Energy one of the world's
leading marine biologists leading NOAA a
CTO and a CIO chief technology officer
and chief information officer in the
executive branch for the first time his
priorities have also been reflected in
his budget science got an enormous boost
in the stimulus recovery package
formerly known as the American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act ARRA and in the FY
2009 omnibus and the FY 2010 budget NIH
NIST NOAA DoD basic research do-e
science all getting major boosts in some
2009 2010 or the highest federal
research spending in history tens of
billions more were in the stimulus for
information technology transportation
infrastructure applied energy technology
the ààra and the FY 2010 budget added
something over two billion dollars to
NASA I'll come back to that later
priorities are also reflected in budget
goals clean energy and energy efficiency
are targeted to get a hundred and fifty
billion dollars over ten years 15
billion a year an enormous boost in that
domain and in the national academy
speech the president announced a goal
for national investment in R&D public
and private combined to reach and exceed
3 percent of GDP a level it has never
achieved at the height of the space race
it got to 2.9 percent of GDP priorities
have also been reflected in presidential
events this is the president hooked up
by video link to the astronauts on the
International Space Station the kids in
the background are middle school science
students from around the DC area next to
me is senator kay Bailey Hutchison a
Republican from Texas the ranking member
of the Senate Committee on Commerce
transportation and science and you can
see by the smile on the president's face
that he's enjoying this this is in the
Roosevelt Room in the White House the
discovery astronauts with their
colleagues on the Internet
Space Station he has talked also to the
Atlantis astronauts while they were
still in orbit he welcomed the discovery
astronauts after they got back for an
animated and energetic conversation in
the Oval Office he is immensely
interested in and excited about space
and he is immensely excited by getting
kids interested in space again as you
can see in that last picture but the
administration has done more still in
science and technology very early in his
term instructed on my office to prepare
new guidelines for across the executive
branch on scientific integrity there
will be no more altering of scientists
conclusions by political minders either
at NASA or anywhere else in the
executive branch the visa mantas
procedures have been substantially
revised this was effective a week ago
Friday there was an article in The New
York Times about it but it considerably
understated what has actually been done
there's been a substantial modification
of procedures which is going to
drastically reduce both the backlog and
the wait time for visas for graduate
students postdocs and research
scientists and professors in science and
technology STEM education significant
amounts of the recovery package money
for education is going to go to science
lab science teacher training we're going
to restore Space Science and Technology
and establish clean energy as sources of
inspiration and sources of learning
there is a new effort already named
re-energized into which the Department
of Energy and NSF are putting
substantial funds to get that done let
me turn to some of the issues that the
space program faces and you all in this
audience most of you at least know
already what these issues are without my
listing them there is a disparity
between vision and budget and an
associated gap in the capacity of the
United States to put US astronauts into
space on us launchers the last president
articulated a grand vision for returning
Americans to the moon and going to the
Mars but without providing budgets to
match the president never requested in
the Congress
provided the budgets that would enable
serious pursuit of that vision the
attempt to deal with the mismatch
stretch stressed budgets all across NASA
but still without finding enough money
to implement the vision and now we face
a gap of five years or more between the
end of shuttle operations scheduled at
the end of 2010 and the availability of
a successor capability in the
constellation program to put US
astronauts in space with u.s. launchers
we have both fragility and gaps in the
earth observation satellite fleet the
National polar-orbiting Earth
observation satellite series in post
which is a joint venture of NASA NOAA
and the Department of Defense is far
behind schedule and over budget due in
part to poor coordination and
cooperation among those agencies this
problem threatens the quality of our
long-range weather forecasts and our
hurricane tracking among other things
the Landsat earth observation satellite
series is in fragile condition with
failed instruments the remaining
satellites operating beyond their intent
of life and gaps impending this
threatens the continuity of climate and
vegetation monitoring data sets that are
extremely important for understanding
what's happening on planet earth and
there are issues for the Aeronautics
program Aeronautics research has long
suffered in NASA from inadequate budgets
above all recently and that has had
impacts on the pace of advances needed
to modernize our antiquated air traffic
control system sad impacts on research
to further improve fuel efficiency and
reduce the noise of civil aviation
aircraft impacts on understanding the
intersection and envelopes of fuel burn
air pollution and noise taken together
look for a moment at the air traffic
control issue the costs of congestion
and delays in the u.s. civil aviation
system currently have been estimated at
figures ranging from ten to forty
billion dollars a year the ten billion
dollar figures from the Department of
Transportation the forty billion dollar
figure is from the Joint Economic
Committee of the Congress the use of non
state-of-the-art tracking and
communication technologies is
contributing to congestion as well as to
fuel inefficient routing and fuel waste
in holding
it's also a safety issue of course and
in the face of all this US civil air
traffic is forecasted to increase as
much as two fold by 2025 if you look at
the energy environment issue my
advertised topic for today I finally get
to it for a moment this is a diagram a
little hard to read I'm sure in most of
the room we call this in the energy
business the spaghetti diagram it tells
you what the flow from sources to
end-uses is in the petroleum liquid
sector of the US energy economy for 2007
the width of the arrows represents the
magnitude of the flow the key point is
the jet fuel in 2007 the the fuel for
the civil aviation industry as well for
the military about 1.6 million barrels a
day of that 1.2 1.3 is Civil Aviation
the rest is military that compares to a
considerably larger number in motor
gasoline over 9 million barrels a day
total US imports for comparison about 12
million barrels a day the oil
consumption then is not a large fraction
of the total but it's not insignificant
either US oil consumption going into jet
fuel is in the range of Prudhoe Bay and
its peak production just as a comparison
for you and of course has already
suggested the growth potential in
aviation is large in the United States
and worldwide Aviation's contributions
to total greenhouse gas emissions
measured in terms of global warming
potential is in the range of five
percent of the total again not dominant
but not insignificant either and it is
forecasted to grow substantially if you
look at the opportunities for dealing
both with the energy use oil dependence
and
environmental impact dimension of this
obviously one leverage point is the fuel
economy of the aircraft how well do they
do in terms of energy use / revenue
passenger mile that's the units in this
diagram again a little hard to read but
it starts at 1965 on the left and goes
to 2025 on the right and the dotted line
up the mid
as the year 2000 which when this study
was done was the end of the historical
data in the beginning of the forecasts
the upper dark line on the left is the
US fleet average at actual load factor
the line at the bottom is the US fleet
average at the 2000 load factor of 0.72
and the individual dots are different
aircraft that came into use in the years
indicated crucial thing here is
summarized at the bottom in the late
1960s the typical fuel economy for civil
jet aircraft was 3 to 4 mega joules per
revenue passenger kilometer by 2025 we
expected to be 1/4 to 1/3 of that one
mega Joule per revenue passenger
kilometer this is immense progress in
increasing the efficiency of jet
aircraft and somewhat comparable
progress has been made in reducing the
noise from civil aircraft which has been
very important further reductions in
specific fuel burn are desirable and
expected they should be accelerated but
interestingly the cost of emissions
permits under a cap-and-trade system on
greenhouse gases is going to add only
modestly to the incentives for doing
that it is quite likely that when a
cap-and-trade system goes into effect
probably in 2012 if we managed to pass
out of the Congress this year the
cap-and-trade legislation currently
embodied in the waxman-markey bill it's
unlikely for some years to come that the
permit price will go over about $30 per
tonne of carbon dioxide that's 110
dollars per ton of contained carbon and
that only translates to about 30 cents a
gallon again that's not negligible but
it's probably not as important to the
airlines as the bigger fluctuations that
occur in the price of fuel in the global
oil market coal to liquids tar sands oil
shale could all help with our oil import
dependence but without carbon dioxide
capture and sequestration those options
for alternative fuels for jet aircraft
actually make climate change worse they
increase by a substantial margin the
total greenhouse gas
per liter of fuel in the airplane and of
course the motor vehicle solutions for
reducing mobile greenhouse gas emissions
plug-in hybrids pure electric cars
hydrogen vehicles either don't work at
all for aircraft or they require radical
aircraft redesign as in the case they
have a hydrogen fueled aircraft this
means that the main short and midterm
focus for reducing aircraft greenhouse
gas emissions beyond what fuel improved
fuel economy can achieve has to be
converting sustainably grown biomass to
something that's essentially the
equivalent of kerosene the currently
most promising way to do this is
fischer-tropsch liquids produced from
cellulosic biomass this is a technology
that basically works we know how to do
it it's been done for years on a small
scale but we need substantially more
research and development on the
compatibility of these fuels mixed with
conventional jet fuel on their emissions
characteristics engine performance and
so on let me turn now to what's being
done on these problems in the aerospace
domain on the Aeronautics side next-gen
the next generation air transportation
system a public-private partnership to
transform u.s. civil aviation by 2025 it
was initiated by Congress in 2003 in the
last administration through an act of
Congress called vision 100 the century
of aviation reauthorization Act it's led
by the Department of Transportation and
the FAA with participation by NASA DoD
Department of Homeland Security NOAA and
the Office of Science and Technology
Policy which I direct it's managed by a
joint planning and Development Office
and the next-gen senior policy committee
on which I sit it has a number of
interesting features in the air traffic
control domain automatic dependent
surveillance and broadcast which is
going to enable both pilots and
controllers to see the same real-time
displays of air traffic which should
substantially improve safety while
increasing system capacity system-wide
information management has the wonderful
acronym swim
to reduce redundancy and facilitate
information sharing and next-gen data
communications technologies that are
going to allow for much better exchange
of all kinds of information between
pilots and controllers and as a result
undoubtedly increase the productivity
capacity and safety of our civil air
system we have a National Aeronautics
R&D policy since 2006 that was produced
by the Office of Science and Technology
Policy in the National Science and
Technology Council which is an
interagency body which OSTP organizes
with the deputy heads of the various
relevant cabinet agencies and other
executive branch agencies that R&D
policy enunciates overall goals
including increased efficiency fuel
availability and Environmental
Protection and it was made official
policy by an executive order in the last
administration as a guide to Aero R&D
efforts through 2020 going with it and
materializing the next year in 2007 a
national plan for aeronautics R&D and
related infrastructure that included
specific goals mostly numerical versus
time for engine efficiency improvements
alternative fuels emissions and noise
the FAA has an aviation climate change
research initiative organized under
next-gen to advance mostly these same
goals cleaner quieter more efficient
aircraft technologies and the
development and demonstration of
alternative fuels for aviation it is
being supported by something called the
continuous lower energy emissions and
noise again another wonderful acronym
clean misspelled but clean nonetheless
it's a partnership of FAA with industry
another initiative in there is the
commercial aviation alternative fuels
initiative which is public private and
indeed international in the partnerships
involved NASA has got something called
the environmentally responsible aviation
project authorized in the 2010 budget
new effort focused on both aircraft
technologies and on aviation operations
to get at some of these issues what's
being done in space I mentioned before
that to begin addressing NASA's budget
problems to plus billion got added to
the FY 9 and 10 budgets in the Recovery
Act and the FY 2010 request the trick is
how to finish addressing the budget
problems a little over a week ago a
couple weeks ago now retired general and
former astronaut Charlie Bolden was
nominated by the President as the new
head of NASA there was a lot of
complaining out there that there wasn't
a new NASA head this was taken by some
to be an indication that the
administration wasn't really interested
in space not true for a whole variety of
reasons the process of selecting a new
NASA Administrator proved to be more
time-consuming than expected but we were
working at it all along I spent a lot of
time with Charlie Bolden in the initial
interviews and then in meetings with him
and the president and I would say that
he clearly understands the challenges of
budget and rebalancing the NASA faces
including balancing space versus
Aeronautics balancing human versus
robotic exploration balancing
exploration versus science and balancing
looking up versus looking down he's got
a big challenge ahead of him he knows it
but he has deep understanding of the
program deep experience with the program
and I think is going to make an
excellent
NASA Administrator there is as has
already been mentioned a new blue-ribbon
panel chaired by norm Augustine that
will report to me the NASA Administrator
and the president by August on the
options for the human spaceflight
program going forward questions that
that panel will be addressing is can we
figure out any way to reduce the gap in
the capacity of the United States to put
astronauts in space on our own launchers
it will look at what the options might
be for extending the life of the
International Space Station beyond 2016
it seems a terrible waste for everybody
to have put
the immense amount of money that's going
into that into that space station and
then not get the full scientific value
out of it
panel we'll look at how we think about
the timetable for missions beyond
low-earth orbit given the likely budget
constraints going forward and some more
the Earth observing satellite issues are
also starting to get addressed my office
is convening the principal's from NASA
NOAA and indeed the Commerce Secretary
as well and the Department of Defense to
address the cooperation and coordination
problems that have plagued that that
program and I'm optimistic that we're
going to turn that around we're
undertaking reviews of Landsat and the
other earth-observing satellite systems
across a wide variety of agencies the
Office of Science and Technology Policy
National Science and Technology Council
of NASA NOAA and the National Academy is
all looking at that but here's where we
end up we end up with a continuing
federal budget challenge that is going
to be extraordinarily difficult what
you're looking at here is FY 2008
through 2014 the big budget categories
many of them non-discretionary Medicaid
Medicare Social Security and of course a
big chunk of Department of Defense the
amount left over for other discretionary
out of which the space program and
Aeronautics have to come is is not very
big and looking pretty flat so it is
really going to be a huge challenge to
get everything done we need to get done
and want to get done in this domain in
this budget situation my closing
observation is that President Obama has
been very clear that in order to succeed
in this challenging environment we're
going to need all hands on deck what
that means is that the Science and
Technology community and its aerospace
component are going to have to come
together they're going to have to come
together across government industry
universities the academies of science
and engineering other professional
societies and NGOs and across countries
in new levels of commitment
communication and cooperation I would
say that giant leaps are going to
require giant partnerships thank you
very much
thank you
we're going to take just three questions
from the floor for dr. Holdren and then
I will invite our panelists up for a
broader discussion and please come to
the mics Einstein said
Roosevelt a letter in the late 30s and
by the early 30s and it's were
threatening we were able to go ahead on
fishing and produce a whole city in Oak
Ridge Tennessee which I happen to be in
tonight and and other facilities in
Columbia and later for the other and why
is it why don't we have the leadership
now to do something like this because a
case could be met I think made is that
the threat that the United States of now
on the energy crisis is comparable or
somewhat comparable or maybe even worse
than was World War two and and and yet
that's not happening I know when in
Livermore they were supposed to fire off
the 192 blazes last week I don't haven't
seen anything of that but why don't we
have that pressure well the first thing
I would say is I would I would agree
with your tentative proposition that the
energy challenge is more difficult than
the challenge of building the first
atomic bomb it's more difficult than the
challenge of going to the moon and the
the frequently heard remark that if we
could build the atomic bomb if we could
go to the moon we can certainly solve
solve the energy challenge in a way
might be right but it understates the
magnitude of the energy challenge the
president in proposing a hundred and
fifty billion dollars over ten years to
start to address the energy challenge in
the science and technology domain in a
more responsible way is a recognition of
the magnitude of the problem I should
tell you by comparison
that what the United States has been
spending on federal energy R&D the total
fish infusion fossil renewables
transmission and distribution the whole
works and fundamental energy science has
been about three billion dollars a year
so by proposing an additional 15 billion
dollars a year he's proposing to
increase the US investment in federal
energy research development and
demonstration by a factor of six I mean
this is a gigantic increase in a
response that most folks think is in the
ballpark of what we would need to
increase the pace of innovation in
energy technology to the place that
would have to be to give us the options
we're going to need to address this
array of challenges in a cost-effective
way so I think this president does
understand how big this challenges and
the question is will the Congress let us
have the money yes I'm Allan clump MIT
of 59 and contributor to the power
program and other space programs working
recently on energy and environmental
problems have you considered the
possibility of hydrogen powered
airplanes there follow essentially a
recent Boeing design that have a fuel
tank in the front and rear of the
passenger compartment because of the
much greater volume needed to be power
airplanes by by hydrogen and the
hydrogen could be transported from solar
or wind farms to the airports using the
star super cables which which conduct
superconn electricity superconductive
lee on the outside where the cables are
cool cooled by transporting liquid
hydrogen at near zero temperatures on
the inside the short answer is yes we're
looking at everything believe me
III get about six interesting proposals
a day across the transom in the Office
of Science and Technology Policy we look
at them all what I meant by saying that
powering aircraft with hydrogen requires
radical redesign it applies to that to
that case that doesn't mean we shouldn't
do it but it means it's likely to take
longer and we need to do a good many
other things in the meantime but but I
think the possibilities ultimately of
hydrogen powered aircraft are very
interesting yeah I figure that my
grandchildren's grandchildren will be
able to fly on those air without
emissions anywhere in the world third
one yes yeah hi my name is Peter Shyam
it's I'm with the Smithsonian this may
go against the the general way that
space and space science is done or just
the plans the way people think but I
have always thought to improve the
innovation we need to shrink the size
the projects make many many many more
for the same amount of money but we also
need to reduce the emphasis on success
obviously we're not doing I'm not
talking about dealing with human
involved flight but space robotic kinds
of things there's there's always this
emphasis on near hundred percent so that
drives the price up it also drives the
time out and I was I was kind of shocked
to see that that the the Gemini program
put up so many flights in two years
yesterday I was asked how quickly I
could do anything in space and I said
well minimum maybe three years I was
kind of chuckling to myself that we had
I don't know ten ten Gemini flights in
two years I don't think I could do that
now especially with the rules so I was
thinking that something along the lines
of the Neo sont CubeSat program which is
much much too small but but you know
Ames is working on things that are maybe
three or four times that size but in the
range of the four to six million dollars
and maybe have 10 or 15 of those a year
and you'd really see an explosion and
you know
Asian out of science and engineering
obviously that's not going to be the up
lookers that you're talking about
because those have to be extraordinarily
large but down lookers and and Institue
and space weather and things like that
all could be done in that kind of range
yeah I am aware of thinking of this sort
that is going on in looking at the
options we're getting better at looking
down in more cost-effective ways
certainly that that is something that is
under consideration I think there's some
interesting ideas in there
[Applause]
thank you very much
I'd like to introduce our panelists who
all work in this domain of air
transportation and environment and
energy first Mike Bair is vice president
of business strategy and marketing for
Boeing Commercial Airplanes he leads
their strategic business planning and
marketing activities he was also the
lead for the team that developed a new
787 dreamliner and was responsible for
all aspects of that airplane program
among his several degrees one of them is
an MBA from our Sloan School of
Management seated next to him is Dave
Danielson Dave started I think just two
months ago all right two months ago is
one of the founding program managers
within the US Department of Energy's
Advanced Research Project agency -
energy arpa-e a new agency designed to
accelerate the development of
transformational high-risk high-reward
new energy technologies prior to that he
was in the business of being a venture
capitalist working on clean energy and
prior to that he's I think best known
here at MIT is the founder of our MIT
energy Club which was something that
started from an idea and very rapidly
grew to include about a thousand people
involved in that so it was sort of
dramatic level of interest seated next
to Dave is Alan Epstein Alan is a
currently vice president of technology
and environment for Pratt & Whitney he's
responsible for their long term
technology and environmental strategy
he's also the RC Maclaurin professor in
aeronautics and Astronautics at MIT he
has a long history of working on
problems of aerospace propulsion power
and energy he also as a student worked
on the Apollo 11 landing at the MIT
instrumentation laboratory as an
electronics technician so he was in very
early in that program seated next to
Alan is dr. Lourdes Maurice Lourdes is
the chief scientist
chief scientific and technical adviser
for environment within the Federal
Aviation Administration's office of
Environment and Energy she's there a
primary technical lead for all basic and
exploratory research advanced technology
development that focuses on
environmental impacts as well as
alternative fuels she also manages a
program that I lead so I've had the
benefit of having a very close
collaboration with her for seven years
so this is a very talented set of
panelists and I'm going to ask them each
a question just to get things started
and then we'll open it up for all the
panelists for questions from the floor
so first Mike if I may start with you
given what you've heard today about
Apollo and air transportation and energy
environment and some of the challenges
that John listed here um what do you
take is the important lessons and what
role can big commercial aerospace
playing in providing some solutions very
good actually I get to reinforce some of
the comments that John made which is
always great as opposed to arguing the
people first there just a couple of
quick facts 8% of the world's GDP 30
million jobs 40 percent by value of all
the exports depend upon commercial air
transportation so you throw those
numbers in and all the intangible things
that air transportation brings the world
so the fact that we get at shoes in the
winter something other than oranges for
fruit and cabbage for vegetables the
fact that we can gather people like this
together from around the world around
the country to have these sort of these
sort of conferences the fact that people
can travel to different countries and
realize that we're more alike than
different all dependent upon air
transportation so clearly a huge and
very important industry to the United
States and to the world in general so
it's obviously to our best interest to
do everything we can to further the
development of this industry the
industry has had a wonderful history it
grows faster than GDP that's a journey
that we are really really interested in
continuing but we have two really major
channel
that we face in this industry one is
economics as a capital goods provider to
the airline the Airlines it's not lost
on us that they have failed to return
their cost to capital over their entire
history not a good thing so that needs
to be addressed
it's an awful business model second one
is obviously our carbon footprint and as
was indicated we're small single digits
of the problem I think if you were to
ask us probably as an industry and
certainly my company maybe three or four
years ago what we should do our response
would have been leave us alone and go
pick on the people that really matter
clearly that's not a not a constructive
approach and we've decided over the last
few years that we need to be far more
responsible on what we do in terms of
addressing you know our contribution to
global climate change especially given
the fact that we are going to continue
to grow faster than GDP so we are not
going to be a smaller part of the
problem but a bigger part of the problem
unless we do something so those are two
big problems
the good news for us is that unlike most
of the issues that we all work at the
answers to these two problems are not
compromises between them because the the
the answers for one tend to support the
others so we got things that we can do
to effect change in both this regard and
what we do and one will help the other
side and we're really focused on three
major thrusts and they were mentioned by
John first is fuel efficiency we've had
a great ride since the start of the jet
age we've improved the fuel efficiency
of the airplanes some 70 percent pretty
remarkable but that's you know with jet
with jet airplanes that's 50 years worth
of technology with aluminum airplanes at
70 years worth of technology we're kind
of running out of ideas and that's
really what the 787 is all about it's a
step function change twenty percent
improvement over what we can do today is
what the 787 represents but probably
even more important than that 20 percent
step function
is that it's the start of a new journey
everything that that airplane brings to
the marketplace and all the technology
that we put in that airplane
we've also John generate a laundry list
of things that we can do better when we
do the second generation 787 type
airplane so we're off on another journey
to continue to make dramatic
improvements in fuel efficiency but it
doesn't stop there on fuel efficiency I
think one of the things that we
recognize is that we are going to have
to affect regulation and we are as a
company and I think as an industry
trying to get fuel efficiency standard
standards mandated on our industry and
what our approach is hopefully is to get
them modeled somewhat after the noise
standards that were put in place some
3035 years ago that have been remarkably
effective even though they have been
diametrically opposed opposed to the
economics of the industry so we think
there is great merit in a fuel
efficiency standard being imposed on
this industry and are actively
advocating that happen second as was
managed or as was mentioned as air
traffic management not a failure in
technology a failure in policy and
around the world technologies that have
been in existence for decades could
improve the fuel efficiency and
therefore the carbon footprint in the
industry by 12% across the board and all
it takes is a political will to
implement them and that is a that is
low-hanging fruit by the definition of
low-hanging fruit and lastly the the
ultimate what we think is the ultimate
solution for the industry is biofuels as
has has been mentioned we cannot find
any alternative fuel source that has the
energy densities that allow us to build
airplanes that are cost-effective so we
are going to be the last burners in our
view last burners of hydrocarbons left
on earth
so those hydrocarbons have to be
friendly we are absolutely confident
that biofuels are the answer we've done
enough enough science on them and an
actual test to know the chemistry works
we are actively pursuing certification
of the
the next real step is in industrializing
the production of the biofuels and while
we are not an insignificant use of
petroleum the numbers that we burn are
sufficient that you can get your arms
around a biofuel solution for the
aerospace industry so those are the
three major thrusts that we are focused
on at the blong company good thank you
my Dave you were a catalyst here at MIT
you were a venture capitalist working
for a company that had that in its name
and now you're charged with in the do-e
of being a catalyst as one of the
founding program managers at arpa-e from
your perspective being a relatively sort
of young participants in things what
should we do to inspire
technical leadership and you know how do
we give the young technical leaders all
the tools that they need to sort of
achieve the sort of a great steps board
that we need well first you know after
two months at arpa-e getting the things
set up 18-hour days no weekends I don't
know young I feel but I will try to
speak for the young folks by the way a
number a large number of people in your
federal government are working really
really hard to get the recovery money
out the door and to keep the energy
innovation humming and so I think that's
something we should all appreciate you
know I'm brand new to government and I
was just really impressed with with the
level of work and the quality of the
people and the devotion that is
happening at the Department of Energy
and other parts of the government so I
thought that I might frame this in an
interesting way
so I thought to myself forty years from
now when we run this event at MIT but
for energy who will be the astronauts in
energy innovation who we will look to
look look at as people who in their
early in their early 20s or early 30s or
or at an event like this and who will be
those people who actually did transform
our energy economy and also I was
thinking what what will have been their
sputnik's what will be the things that
drew them in to devote their lives to
this
so one thing that Ian asked me to
comment on is you know how do we inspire
young people my first answer is that
they're already incredibly inspired it
didn't take much to get 1,500 MIT
students to join the MIT energy Club
everyone is incredibly fired up they in
many cases people are devoting more time
to you know multidisciplinary energy
studies through the energy club than
they are to their thesis which many
advisors don't like it and indeed my
successor is the president of the energy
Club his advisor found out about his
being the president of the energy Club
when he heard him on NPR driving in to
work so you know like I said a
tremendous amount of interests like 1500
students who are actively engaged in
weekly or bi-weekly hardcore energy
discussions and dialogues on campus at
MIT even more interesting I think is
that MIT student founded something
called the collegiate Energy Association
which represents essentially a
consortium of energy clubs across the
country and around the world and at this
point there are 25 similar clubs that
other universities across the country
for in Europe - in Canada 3 and Asia and
one in China and I think that that that
bodes well that these students these
leaders are actually getting together
once a year and discussing the energy
problem and so you know these young
leaders are are forward-looking enough
to engage each other you know from China
to the United States to Europe you know
those kind of international
collaborations going to be needed going
forward so I think that bodes really
well so I thought a little bit about so
there's been a tremendous amount of
activity in the last five years even
when I came to in the last 10 years
especially when I came to MIT in 2001 to
begin my PhD work in photovoltaics I
couldn't find a single professor to work
with I couldn't find anyone who was
working on solar photovoltaics and now
in 2009 if we look if we look at what we
have now
there are at least 50 60 folks full-time
working in this area so we've got an
order to two orders of magnitude more
innovation going on which is a very
exciting to me so what it what is it
that drove that you know these large
numbers you know this is a huge ramp and
interest and you know is it real is it
is it gonna be going away I don't think
so and I think that if so my hypothesis
for the people that will be sitting up
here as as the astronauts of this new
energy generation are gonna you know I'm
biased because I do come from the
Entrepreneurship world I believe they're
going to be energy entrepreneurs and
innovators and inventors that are truly
going to invent transformative new
technologies or greatly increase the
cost effectiveness and performance of
existing energy technologies to get us
to a low-carbon low energy costs you
know secure energy future so if you look
if you look at so I kind of thought of a
few things that I think represent a
number of sputnik's that really in
inform the kind of young people that are
leading that I think will be leading
going forward the first is a maybe
counterintuitive the internet boom of
the late 90s I believe that that made
entrepreneurship personal I think that
doing a start-up became a very
reasonable thing to do and that most
people in their you know early 20s and
30s
think hey I could do a start-up and I
think you know you imagine 20 years ago
doing an energy startup seemed like a
pretty crazy idea but there are there
are hundreds if not thousands of energy
startups right now I think that very
formative for many of us young energy
innovators was were the 9/11 attacks you
know there's a very vivid memory for all
of us that gave us pause as to our role
in the world and there are energy
implications that relate to that the oil
price spike was actually a big one 2004
I started the energy Club in 2004 and
2005 it the I think that my membership
went up almost in lockstep with oil
prices so I think back gave everyone
pause as to you know can we run a modern
economy if we need to rely on expensive
oil
Hurricane Katrina you know it it a you
know it was not a reasonable thing to
directly attribute that to climate
change I think gave everyone an example
of the kind of future we could
potentially be looking at in a world
where climate change is not mitigated
and global instability
you know wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
weigh heavily on a lot of young people
as well and then most recently the
economic crisis I think that a number of
young people believe that a way for us
to invent our way out of that is to
actually you know reinvent our economy
and develop a completely new
infrastructure based upon clean energy
so what that so those are a number of
sputnik's maybe too many but if you
actually look at young people who are
devoted devoting their lives to energy
there it really informs what they're all
about I think if you look at folks who
devoted their lives energy in the late
70s you see a really stark difference
there are folks who got who committed
their lives to more traditional energy
production and are very proud of that I
talked to them frequently and and that
they providing low cost domestic energy
to is critical in order for the economy
to move forward and then there are a set
of environmentalist who typically put
themselves outside of the energy system
and pounded on it from outside in trying
to potentially slow it or shut it down I
think if you look at the the new
generation what you see in the new
generation of energy innovators and
young energy young people devoting my
life's energy it's much more about
getting inside the Machine getting
inside the economic apparatus and
actually inventing technologies and
getting them deployed with with
appropriate policies to try to solve all
of these problems you know low cost
energy we all want low cost energy it's
it's critical for the economy and it's
critical for the developing world
low-carbon energy is critical to avoid
climate change issues and secure energy
is mission critical in order to avoid
global instability so I see it as a very
young people are very entrepreneurial
about this and they look at it is we're
gonna solve all these things and we're
gonna use more market innovations to
actually do it
so I guess they you know a few things of
a few comments about what what young
energy innovators are going to need to
be up here in 40 years and to be able to
say that we've made a big impact one is
clear and it's so obvious I'll just
briefly mention is the policy you know
the policy needs to be in place such
that when entrepreneurs build these new
products that are low that do represent
the clean energy products that will
reinvent the economy and a low-carbon
economy
we need to have policy to build a bridge
to this because you need to be able to
have a product that can be sold in the
market funding is huge like I said in
not in in 2001 there was not funding for
anyone to do solar and now with their
sufficient funding at MIT MIT is this is
very exciting I think it was five years
ago it was last time I sat up here next
to Susan Hockfield when she announced
her energy initiative and now the Energy
Initiative has raised 250 million
dollars that they'll be spending over
the next five years on energy innovation
at MIT and that's happening across the
board so there's a ton going on but we
do need more funding we definitely need
more funding we are by no means anywhere
close to being idea limited or human
resources limited many more people have
ideas and want to get involved in energy
than there's funding to support it now
one big you know the young generation of
energy innovators there's a real this is
a big difference I've seen there's a
real focus on multidisciplinary study
and collaboration in many of my
interactions with with older folks and
the energy and the energy sphere they
tend to be somewhat focused on silos
either let's say science and technology
on the business side or on the policy
side and what I'm seeing that the young
energy innovators is that there's a
seamless transition of between that
triad of you know policy cannot exist in
a vacuum outside of technology in
business and all of the other three
interactions so the multidisciplinarity
is that I think a big trend that is new
one area where we do need some more work
is in this idea of thinking big you know
a lot of the biggest companies that have
come out of MIT have been kind of driven
by what I would call alpha P
you know PhD folks strong technical
folks who or just those alpha dogs who
really were willing to think massive
billion-dollar companies we still have a
reasonable number of those alpha folks
my own colleagues are my contemporaries
between them I I have they've raised you
know I'll probably run within ten people
around 100 million in venture capital
and are doing are pursuing huge ideas in
drilling technology and solar in in
energy storage and other areas if any of
those pop it could make a huge impact
and so I do think that one thing that we
need to do as both that's both more
experienced and younger technical
leaders is to inspire and and help
people understand that if you want to
make a dent and this energy problem
there better be a billion dollar company
coming out of it and when I sometimes
when I go to MIT culture gets that but
when I go speak to universities in
Midwest sometimes I get a lot of eye
rolls how could I ever build a billion
dollar company but I think that that's
that kind of big thinking needs to get
inculcated into young energy leaders and
the other I think I heard some comments
earlier today is this idea of risk I
have found in interacting with with a
lot of strong young technical energy
innovators there is still a little bit
of risk aversion it has to be okay to
fail now this is built into our police
mission for example you got to be able
to fail this is built into venture
capital it's okay to fail you just got
to get up and take another swing at it
so if we're gonna if we're gonna invent
some really important transformational
new technologies we need to make sure
that it's clearly communicated to folks
that it's okay to fail and I think with
that I'll leave that with for you to
think about and look forward to any
questions you may have and I'll look
forward to moderating this panel in 2049
when we're well on our way to see that
starting to transform our energy
infrastructure good thank you Dave
Allen you worked on a Palo as a boy does
it work as you sometimes say now you're
sort of chief technology officer of
including for environment for Pratt what
do you see is the parallels the
differences the lessons
is the country's largest manufacturer of
airplane engines and rocket engines so
there's a yin and the yang and I was
very encouraged by dr. Holdren speech
and I agree totally with it especially
if I can cherry-pick parts of it which
I'll which I'll do now my job didn't
exist two years ago big companies had
VPS for technology they had VPS for
environment but environment in a large
American company and basically
compliance to make sure that you were
conforming to the rules and regulations
of the EPA and and the local state
authorities now we have large
corporations realizing that their future
is tied up to the environment and that
if you don't embrace the environment as
defining the products of the future and
therefore the technologies you need for
the future frankly you're going to end
up like General Motors and Chrysler so I
have a fairly simple business all right
I provide push it really is a business
based upon Newtonian mechanics and 19th
century engineering like I push things
one way of thinking about it it's a boys
way of making money out of sophomore
thermodynamics but but in a large sense
the business comes into it as well so I
have to push an airplane I love Boeing I
love all of God's children who make make
airplanes they have to push an airplane
at most of the speed of sound or faster
if it's a military airplane what I care
about is how much energy it takes to do
it the law of thermodynamics is not
negotiable I may not apply inside the
beltway but it applies to the rest of
the universe right we now have engines
that are their mother a mately fifty
five percent efficient that tells me how
much better I can get I need energy
historically energy has been mined from
the ground in the form of liquid
petroleum slightly processed and I move
it on airplanes as Mike Blair said
pending an invention of new chemistry
that's by far the highest energy dense
source that I can put on an airplane so
I'm gonna stay with a liquid hydrocarbon
but the look what hydrocarbon doesn't
have to come from the ground so long as
the carbon doesn't add to the planets
Carbon burden basically as long as it
comes from the atmosphere then what I've
done is separate the carbon and the
energy the fuel from where the energy
comes from above my desk I have a
picture of the Pratt Whitney hydrogen
airplane engine which is about five feet
in diameter built in 1957-58
for the Air Force a super-secret project
which is a great story but I'm not going
to get into here project Sundance and
why do I keep it there well one is it
shows that you want to go to hydrogen
we're ready to go hydrogen will blow the
dust off the blueprints and build the
engine but it's not a very good airplane
because hydrogen has very low density so
the question is if I'm going to
manufacture the fuel from a renewable or
other clean energy source and I would
say nuclear is a clean energy source
then it could be hydrogen or can be a
hydrocarbon if I'm using solar I can use
solar the good old-fashioned way which
is grow plants biofuel or I could use
some other chemical synthesis technique
like some of the breakthroughs at MIT
but it's going to look like hydrocarbon
kerosene jet fuel going in the airplane
I need 20 billion gallons a year for the
u.s. and 70 billion gallons a year for
the world that sounds like an
industrial-sized process I have another
challenge I was gonna say problem but in
industry I had problems in academia I
now know an industry we only have
challenges the challenge is how do I
convince biofuel producers that they
should produce biofuel for my industry
and and Mike explain why it's so
important to the nation in the world
rather than putting it in automobiles
for example and there are two answers
one is it is more valuable to me because
I don't know how to build an electric
airplane and unless I go maybe a carbon
nanotube extension cords and then they
get tangled after a few thousand miles
so I need the hydrocarbon fuel I think
as there's more scholarship that's come
out recently
were you looking not just the greenhouse
gases from a particular mode of
transportation or industry but the total
footprint of that industry so the total
footprint of transportation you see that
indeed not only is aviation relatively
green but a much larger fraction of its
total footprint including the
infrastructure that supports it is the
fuel burned in the vehicle versus the
thousands of kilometres of railroad
track and Road bed and highway that we
do for other modes and so therefore
there's a bigger gain to the environment
by investing biofuels into aviation for
the same number of gallons of biofuel
then you get from putting it into two
ground transportation so that's sort of
the physics of it now it has has to come
out to make monetary sense what is
monetary sense mean is do I have to pay
more for the fuel probably it's thirty
cents a gallon a lot of fuel well in
year 2000 fuel was 90 cents a gallon
thirty cents would have destroyed the
industry fuels now 250 gallon 30 cents
is moaning groaning a year ago at 4 420
a gallon spot price 30 cents wasn't so
so scary a number what this implies to
me is inside the beltway there has to be
an immense amount of thought on policy
and policy is applied to aviation and a
one-color policy for all of industry or
all of Transportation probably is not
the wisest course but I think that
biofuels are the solution we've improved
airplanes since the 707 commercial
airplanes by two-and-a-half percent a
year on on average we're about halfway
to the theoretical maximum I think we
can continue to do two and a half
percent a year but if aviation grows at
four to five percent a year there's a
gap and that gap has to come from low
carbon biofuels and to get 20 billion
gallons a year that takes large industry
and large investment so so I need two
things I need from the financial
community substantial capital to do this
and if you say how much was standard
refinery for 70 billion gallons a year
it's about 500 million dollars five
hundred billion dollars of capital a
couple years ago I thought that was a
lot of money now in Washington half a
trillion doesn't seem like all that much
but capitals hard to raise so what else
do I need
I need the kinds of ingenuity and
invention we've come to expect from
places like MIT that gives us better
biofuels better conversion processes
where both the capital requirements and
the energy overhead of doing it goes
down and I think that both of those are
perfectly feasible and that we will see
biofuels as the fuel of choice for
aviation slowly coming in over the next
10 years and then increasing to a larger
and larger fraction of the total IO
total fuel load so that aviation becomes
almost carbon free now my job is not
carbon environment it's an environment
and what's environment for aviation
aviation has been at the head of
environmental concerns since the
invention of the airplane there's a new
newspaper weekly newspaper 1911 called
the arrow published in Britain
now-defunct the funk since 1913 and they
had an editorial decrying the racket
that airplanes made and they said this
prejudice is the public against them
what was true nine
eleven we're now 1959 was the first
commercial jet flight in the United
States a Pratt & Whitney powered Boeing
707 American Airlines Los Angeles to New
York and what happened when those jet
planes went in people complained about
noise well it's a big topic in
Washington now the FAA wanting to move
the noise contours around New York so we
have to bring noise down we have to
bring local air quality down we don't
get a bye on any of those as we bring
our carbon footprint down and so what
you're going to see is the the sorts of
ingenuity that American University's
American businesses are brought to bear
to reduce all of the environment while
delivering the value to the airline
customers they'll let them hopefully
someday make a profit and keep keep
things low so I mean I'm very optimistic
about what goes on and I welcome dr.
Holdren challenge I say yes the only
thing that concerns me my last word
would be that a lot of the aerospace
technology that we now enjoy in our new
products came out of joint industry
government partnership through NACA and
then NASA and the atrophy of NASA
Aeronautics has meant that we've just
about pumped that well dry and so we
have to re-examine how we as a nation
can work together to meet some of these
goals and the last thing let me say is
when I came here as a freshman my first
lecture was in this room and over 40
years I've slept through some really
good lectures here and I'm glad to see
many of you who stayed awake thanks
Lourdes many of the programs that were
in dr. holdren slides are programs that
not only provide the technical
leadership for but you initiated them
and got them up and through the
government system to make them a reality
so you've had some success not only on
exploring the environmental challenges
for aviation but also getting some real
changes for research within the
government so I welcome you to tell us
about your thoughts about what still
needs to be done and what we can do
better well thanks again I really
appreciate the opportunity to be here
certainly as I look ahead in what one
could do as we move forward and sort of
want to think beyond this hallowed
institution of MIT because in some ways
I think that everything that we as a
community can do we probably learn when
we were in kindergarten I really like
that book that everything you ever
needed to know you learn in kindergarten
so if I look ahead that's what we need
to do number one is tell the truth
I think that we have some very hard and
difficult challenges to deal with dr.
Holdren pointed out to look at
interdependencies which you and I kind
of started launching that to the other
and I think we have a lot of answers
already and getting the technical part
on with the easy part now communicating
the messages that yes there's trade-offs
between noise emissions energy etc and
we do want everything but there's some
physical realities it's the hard part
and we do need to convey the message and
we need to convey the message to the
average citizen on the one hand and on
the other hand much like dr. Holdren
talked about the real audience of who's
here today is the students and what
difference you can make when I
took my job about seven years ago I
thought the Beltway was a horrible place
and they did terrible things and made
dumb decisions and how could they be
doing all of these things and I said
well you know part of it is you because
you work in this hallowed area of
research and you're not providing input
into the system so tell the truth into
the system and in influence what comes
out the second part that I think we need
to do is be inclusive and if I could
deviate from the subject it's kind of
funny to me that when I went in the back
to get my top the first time I was asked
what are you doing here so upset okay
I'm just here to be my top Saturday you
know one time the second time work what
are you doing here you're in the wrong
place so then the third time is like
where's dr. Maurice so you know
obviously I'm a little bit different
than some of the panelists I think in
some ways though probably more
representative of what most of the world
is like very much a citizen of the world
multicultural multiracial so I think
it's important to consider that I'm
bringing everyone into the solutions but
what I really want to get at is the
thought of as we move forward in dealing
with the energy and environment issues
it's not all about the u.s. everyone's
going to have some input everyone's
going to be part of the decision-making
and we all think a little bit
differently if I look at my education
the most important part of it is the
four years that I spent in the UK and
not because of the grand things I
learned about combustion chemistry but
the fact I was the only quote-unquote
American at a university with folks from
everywhere and I think that's what
sparked my interest in public policy and
as we move forward
dealing with the environmental issues
yeah and all your half of a percent or 5
percent or Taylor died and we all have
got to contribute and in some ways this
little bit of common but differentiated
of who who contributes to hard stop a
barrier on how we move forward but one
that I think perhaps were starting to
put a champion because very quietly the
group on international aviation and
climate change that met here very
recently came out with what some folks
thought was a modest achievement but it
was the very first time that a sector
came out with an aspirational goal that
applied equally to everyone and I think
that if as we move forwards we say ok
this is a challenge this is a problem
we're all in the same ship we need to
deal together and it's not like you've
been polluting 40 years or I'm a little
bit or your this or your dad and you
move forward and do that that will make
a difference and then the last thing
that I think we need to do is kind of
like think about what is it that we want
to do what are what are the barriers and
again I go back to the theme of
kindergarteners I think if I ask folks
in the room how many of you can speak
Chinese how many people would raise
their hands not very many if I ask that
very same question of a bunch of four of
five-year-olds all the hands would go up
and why because everyone can speak
Chinese you just may not be able to
today but you have got the capability to
do that so just figure out what it is
that you want to do and you know my
responsibility is not the whole Korean
economy it's not every sector but I do
play a role within the aviation sector
and I think we're set we we have set up
some very challenge
goals for us they are not fully adopted
yet but we fled out there carbon neutral
growth there in the relatively near
future and then it dropped down and is
it possible
well when setting goals and in a lot of
the goals that are in the national
policy that dr. Holdren talked about it
I've worked on those and do I know how
any of them are going to be achieved
today absolutely not and if I had worked
that you should fire me if I ever set a
goal that I know how to solve today it
has got to be something that I have to
reach for so I think we need to agree
and this is what we're going to do and
it's gonna be hard and it's going to
take a lot of work but we need to work
on it and I think that the last thing
the to deal with this problem of energy
and environment is maybe a little bit
less glossy brochures from the science
programs and a little bit more work into
informing decisions a lot of the
decisions that are going to be made in
particular very cognizant of climate as
we've been working very hard on that but
the very important meeting in Copenhagen
coming up the discussion of what we're
going to do post-kyoto needs to be
informed by science and yes any
scientific endeavors going to lead to a
hundred more questions but I like to
look at my job it's my job is to put
myself out of a job if I'm working on a
problem
my goal ought to be to not be working on
that problem tomorrow the next day and
Sarah to get beyond that and I'm sure
that with the fine education that
institutions like MIT provide folks if
you solve the problem you're working on
I guarantee you that there will be a
host of other problems for you to work
on but don't make your research and your
work
perpetuating your research but about
truly solving the problem thank you
thank you the lordís will take just five
minutes of questions and people can
approach the mic for those questions and
then we'll break for a coffee break some
questions yes sir John you a few years
ago you wrote a beautiful article or the
urgency of the climate problem for the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
now as you pointed out in those article
we have deadlines but when you look at
the solution that your administration
now is beginning to speak about on the
energy problem I don't see a match
between the urgency of the climate
problem and the energy solution you know
take into account what we know that are
being proposed as you know very well the
Department of Energy came out of the AEC
and the chair Wisner when this was done
he approached me asked me Trudeau what
do you think about it well I told him I
was worried well he said look is like
putting good whiney too bad wine nothing
good will come out of it a bit harsh but
something very dramatic has to be done
with the Department of Energy for
example in the context of official
results we have a nuclear deficit in
this country in future you know very
wealthy has been conducting a way that
is ridiculous if we go this way we'll
never do it and so so where are the
departure point that you are able to
offer to us
in terms of meeting you know these
challenges that the climate problem is
posing me somewhat we have to develop
some dramatic way of dealing with it
well first of all I want to assure
everybody that in this administration
the laws of thermodynamics do apply
inside the beltway again yes
and and they apply at the Department of
Energy where we have a Nobel laureate in
physics now in charge
Steve Tru has observed that that he has
discovered a new law of motion since
joining the Department of Energy and
that is that a program in motion tends
to stop but but I think when you say
that something dramatic has to be done
to the Department of Energy you're right
but I think Steve true is going to do it
he's a very bright guy he's got his eye
on the ball he is learning very rapidly
what the intricacies of that department
are and what his problems are and I
think we're going to see a leaner meaner
Department of Energy in terms of its
energy technology research development
demonstration programs I think we're
gonna see a lot happen out of arpa-e I
think we're going to see a lot happen
out of the centers of excellence that
are propagating across the country and
and I do remain optimistic that it's
going to add up to a new pace of
innovation that is going to enable the
United States to do what it needs to do
both to reduce our dependence on foreign
oil and to turn around our greenhouse
gas emissions the way I read the climate
science the United States needs to be
declining in absolute emissions by 2015
yes the president's target calls for
doing that to be back to 1990 by 2020
and to be declining rapidly after that
that's compatible with a family of
trajectories that's consistent with the
sort of global stabilization curve that
we need to be on to have a decent chance
of avoiding climate catastrophe and I
think we're going to get there it's it's
going to take a big portfolio of efforts
we do have to get nuclear energy back on
track we need to get the fusion research
program I agree with you better focused
and but I think under this leadership we
might actually get it done
if the reductions in fossil fuels used
by ground transportation take place as
planned how would that affect would that
be able to keep pace with the increased
demand in fossil fuels by the aviation
industry and if so how would that affect
the timeline for the significant
introduction of biofuels let me say that
the aviation isn't dependent upon fossil
fuels in the future it's dependent upon
hydrocarbon fuels in the future and the
industry is band together to accelerate
the production and certification of
biofuels we've flown demo flights and a
bunch of Boeing airplanes this year
we've been working with all kinds of
fuel producers to try to move their fuel
forward so I'd say I don't want to use
fossil fuels I want to get biofuels and
I want to make sure the biofuel
capability of the nation in the world is
harnessed where it can make the most
good and I think that's a VA ssin I
think one of the things that aside from
climate change that's driving the
interest in in biofuels or alternative
energy and the aviation community is to
control their own destiny I mean if you
look back over the last year
it wasn't the price of oil that killed
the airlines and you all you have to do
is look at the US the US airlines they
were unhedged on the ride up they hedged
at the peak so they lost the same amount
of money on the ride down because
they're hedged too high so they need a
dependable stable sort of fuel and I
think a great example is Air New Zealand
who is moving very quickly to put
together a biofuels program to support
all of their domestic flying now
admittedly not a huge market but there's
an airline who wants to control their
future and they see biofuels his way of
doing that we pretty much I mean that
their argument have been has been made
that well
let all the fossil fuel go to aviation
but beyond we don't want to be the
smokestack industry and if in fact we
want to be ahead and in answer announce
cost the end of Hawaii why should I make
my bow feel for you what we often say is
we have 35 filling stations and what
that means that 80% of the fuel that we
use in the US is deliver our 35 top
airports so our big hurdle is the
certification which I think we're going
to make a big leap on this month you all
planets look aligned for the first
genetic certification although knock on
wood if something can always go wrong
but I think that our industry not only
is committed but it's oh it presents an
excellent example in building the
infrastructure thank you I'm going to
have to end the session because we have
another very interesting session